one hitch
to [ __ ]
hey youtubers is Charlie so surprise
surprise Punisher is officially getting
his own series they dropped a little
teaser this morning so let's talk about
what's going on
the teaser itself is really just to tell
you yeah we're actually working on this
we've hired people you will see this
probably next year they didn't
officially say next year there's no
official premiere date or anything like
that
but if they're going to be rolling into
production later this year that means
they're probably gonna try and get stuff
out next year we should have said first
things first if you haven't watched
daredevil season 2 yet it's kind of like
daredevil versus Punisher you absolutely
have to watch that Frank Castle or Jon
Bernthal as Frank Castle The Punisher
probably the best thing about that
Elektra was a lot of fun but the
Punisher storyline as a whole just
worked so much better than all the other
storylines collectively I know a lot of
you felt the same way I did like oh my
god this Punisher is totally perfect why
doesn't he have his own TV series right
now they're basically just taking that
in they're hiring a bunch of other
people and they're just going to make a
Punisher series now so yes it will be
connected to all the other Netflix
series they haven't confirmed it but yes
he will probably be in defenders they
would leave him out that doesn't
necessarily mean that he's going to be
on the defenders team is it's going to
be a little bit shorter than like a
normal season of daredevil or Jessica
Jones
those are like 13 episodes of season
defenders is probably going to be closer
to like 8 episodes it'll be like a
smaller mini series but it'll just be
bigger more production value it's been
the exact same amount of money on it but
they do fewer episodes so they could
just spend more money per episode to
make it that much crazier but I'll talk
about that in a second let's talk about
punisher stories now they've already
done a couple big punisher stories
during daredevil season 2 like they did
trial of the punisher they did daredevil
vs punisher they even did a version of
punisher max when he gets thrown in
prison so what are they going to do for
punisher season 1 well they'll probably
spell out some of his backstory a little
bit more we'll see more from his time in
the war there's a comic book storyline
called punisher born which actually
deals with this time in vietnam you have
to remember the comic book punisher is a
Vietnam vet TV show punisher is more of
an Afghanistan vets just because they
updated it it's happening in current day
circle of blood is another great
storyline they could do involving the
kingpin because they've already done the
work of setting up their relationship
but the next time we see each other I'm
going to break your face that was a
great move on Daredevils part making the
kingpin a really strong
Punisher villain in addition to being a
daredevil villain there's another story
line called the slavers where Punisher
takes down this human trafficking ring
that feels like a story they could
totally do that's like something you
would see on a CSI episode that the
story does a good job of humanizing the
Punisher it's Garth eNOS so you get to
see all different sides of Punisher you
get to see the dad version of Punisher
as he tries to take care of these people
that he rescues you get to see crazy
hardcore Punisher as you just guns the
[ __ ] out of all these human traffickers
welcome back Frank is another great
Garth eNOS Punisher storyline it has a
lot of humor it sets up a good
supporting cast for the Punisher they're
going to have to build out a Punisher
group of characters that are independent
from the daredevil group of people
because all these series are connected
but in the way Elektra is a daredevil
specific character Punisher needs to
have his own group of characters too so
a lot of that will be the police a lot
of that will be military stuff remember
he has the drive that's probably going
to tee up where he's going in his
spinoff series remember there are a
couple shadow organizations that all the
Netflix series have been teasing like
the company that gave Jessica Jones her
powers the company that experimented on
kilgrave and helped his powers manifest
then you also have the hand raising the
Beast resurrecting Elektra she kind of
is the beast the way they put it during
the daredevil series but we can talk
about that more when we get to Defenders
it's a long ways off but just a reminder
Luke Cage is going to drop in September
this year sweet Christmas in September
they'll probably be a little bit of
Punisher crossover just to help set that
character up defenders is coming next
year
I'm guessing summer release they're
working on it right now if you're
wondering how many seasons all these
shows are going to get Luke Cage iron
fist daredevil Jessica Jones
they'll keep making them till people
stop watching them there's been some
really shitty Netflix series that have
gotten more than three seasons so these
are some of the most popular things that
they've ever done of course they're
going to keep making them for let me
know in the comments what storylines do
you want them to do for the Punisher
season one
I'm guessing welcome back Frank is a
good place to start but don't expect
them to do like a carbon copy of a comic
book storyline they'll just be a lot of
comic book Easter eggs so a lot of big
stuff happened today I'm still working
on a couple videos while you wait for my
next one to post you can click here for
my flash trailer for next week's episode
and you can click here for my spider-man
Civil War video thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you